So watch the sagas array as we run this line of code.
At this point, a new function has been added to the sagas array.
And even though that function is being referenced by a variable in
the global scope, the function itself has the blue type of scope access because
it's fundamentally a blue function that originated inside that red function.
So we've reached the big question.
What do you think is going to happen when we try to run one of
these blue saga functions that was created inside the red context but
is now being accessed from the green context?
Remember the red context that it was created in
has already completed and returned.
So any variables that are referenced by this blue
function from the red context seem perhaps like they should be unavailable.
So, when we invoke this saga sub zero function,
a blue box should appear somewhere in our diagram.
Based on your understanding of how these contexts work,
where would you expect that blue box to appear?